Chris bancaire en Suisse sous la plus
grande banque du pays
UBS et poussé par les autorités à
rachetés d'ici ce soir ça rivale le
Crédit Suisse dont le cours en Bourse
s'est effondré cette semaine en
situation de près ou jour le jour et
qu'il faut le plus vite possible une
solution massive crédible pour l'instant
à vos yeux c'est pas réglé pour
l'instant je n'ai pas d'indication que
la situation se définitivement réglée la
motion ou le pavé ce sont les mots qui
ont été tagués dans la permanence du
député LR Éric Ciotti permanence
vandalisée donc cette nuit à Nice je me
ras à quel moment commencerai la
cérémonie de la tartufferie alors j'ai
commencé allons-y alors vous me demandez
de condamner les violences parce que
c'est la première chose qui vous vient à
l'esprit sur Twitter le président des LR
a réagi jamais
céderai au nouveau disciples de la
terreur monsieur Ciotti et formal placé
pour se plaindre vu que nous n'avons
jamais entendu le son de savoir lorsque
Madame Catherine couturier député de la
Creuse a vu son sa permanence attaquer
quatre fois par des gens parfaitement
identifiés puisque la quatrième fois il
y avait la police qui est à la même
était murée c'est la nupcisation des
esprits la nupacisation dans la forme
qui se prennent tous pour des
sans-culottes révolutionnaires et la
nupcisation des esprits du rassemblement
national jusqu'à même des députés LR
comme Pradier il raisonne tous comme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et comme les gens de
la loupe évidemment qu'aucun d'entre
nous ne peut approuver l'attaque d'une
permanence parlementaire qu'on y jette
des pierres ou autre chose mais si vous
ne voulez pas la violence voici ce qu'il
y a à dire si vous ne voulez pas la
violence acceptez la démocratie aussi
dans quel camp vous plutôt aller au vote
ou plutôt 49 ans je pense que quand on a
une réforme aussi indispensable dans la
situation financière et économique oui
d'autres pays on la joue pas pile ou
face on s'assure on s'assure qu'elle
passe ma conviction intime c'est qu'on
pouvait gagner ce vote
est-ce que vous trouvez que les LR sont
cohérents
les LR ça n'existe plus l'air et ce vote
il a pas lieu du fait d'un groupe qui
n'en est plus un qui n'en est plus en
bas
une manifestation inter syndicale à
Paris qui vire en affrontement hier soir
même scénario la veille à Lyon
avec la taxe de la mairie du 4e
arrondissement par les casseurs le
mouvement se radicalise ou sans te
débordés tout de même en partie pas du
tout non pas du tout c'est à chaque fois
chaque fois il y a des choses qui se
passent en marge des manifestations
alors là c'est évidemment c'est
peut-être plus important mais je le
répète c'est dans quelques villes on a
des syndicats qui sont responsables on a
des manifestants qui sont responsables
on est dans un état de droit on a une
liberté totale de manifester son
opposition à la réforme des retraites et
dans un état de droit force doit rester
au droit jamais la violence alors hier
soir ça vous a rien fait déjà assis par
terre les mains sur les têtes les
brigades de l'Abraham qui chargent des
gens qui sont tranquilles qui vont d'un
endroit à l'autre qui les charges à coup
de matraque ça non mais la permanence de
Monsieur Ciotti la France entière est
dressé ce matin et le discours se durcit
aussi côté syndicat exemplaire à Dijon
avec cette manifestation non autorisée
par la préfecture ne comprend pas que le
gouvernement est surtout le président de
la République ne prennent pas au sérieux
nos alertes c'est tout on est là pour
alerter face à un tel passage en force
je comprends la volonté d'un certain
nombre de citoyens dans un cadre pas
toujours organisé de dire mais on va pas
se laisser faire sans sans réagir et je
pense que le gouvernement a une très
lourde responsabilité le grand
rendez-vous de monde vérité c'est demain
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités
nous avons nous priné l'autre avec la
première ministre avec le président de
la République nous avons fait
collectivement le choix d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conséquence directe de cette situation
oh combien tendu la popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron est au plus bas 70%
d'opinion négatives selon un sondage
Ifop au JDD 14e jour de grève pour les
éboueurs parisiens et les poubelles qui
continuent de s'entasser dans les rues
de la capitale qui croule désormais sous
plus de 10 000 tonnes de déchets